[Música]
o psol decidiu lançar mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar o que fazer e se fala
aqui que vocês têm pedido bastante os
comentários e que está ela como vocês
puderam perceber e vou fazer ela
bastante simples né pouco sol e pediu
para conseguir fazer em casa para não
ficar o bicho não consegue fazer fica um
carro mal não é para fazer um precisar
de cartão do que o normal das caixas
jornais precisa de um pedaço de pau e
lata que a volta à direita de uma sherco
velha é a cola branca e quatro agentes
não tiveram bastante barata a única
coisa que provavelmente vocês vão ter
que comprar serão extintas para pintar a
espada esta que eu usei três cores
prateado e dourado e preto mas se vocês
quiserem fazer como o original só vão
precisar do preto e dora douradão para
que a ninguém é esse agora vamos começar
agora a primeira coisa que você tem que
fazer é colocar em causa a ensinar algo
parecido com isto aqui os gamers corta
usando uma base para não estragar a mesa
no total vamos usar dos seis placas para
ser mais fácil podemos usar o modo como
referência por não estar sendo assim a
mesma coisa por vir cortar em todas as
placas escola em 4 que usando cola braga
veículo laterais marquinhos retângulo
com três por dez centros e este tango
fica centralizado e encostado à borda do
corda e com muito cuidado utilizando
utilizado agora colhem uma placa de um
lado usando cola branca outra vez e
outra do outrora
[Música]
coloquei algumas coisas pesadas em cima
e deixem ficar por algum tempo
agora vocês têm que discutir lá minutos
anunciado tendo cuidado é não
ultrapassar a linha dos 400 no
recipiente misture em três quartos de
cola branca com um quarto da água colin
pedaço de jornal em cima de lever de
forma que fique mais ou menos 50 de fora
podem esperar que segue naturalmente mas
se vocês forem paciente como eu podem
usar um secador virem ao contrário e
como os papéis por cima da lâmina se
quiserem podem passar mais do que uma
camada do jornal para se ficar mais
resistente e corte em pedaços de pvc o
ramo de madeira com 30 centímetros de
comprimento e 3 centímetros de diâmetro
faça-nos quadrados com seus sentimentos
de lado e em cd deus faça os círculos
com três tentos do diâmetro no sempre
vestido e corta em tudo com muito
cuidado
como o primeiro quadrados em furo com
cola branca ou quente e depois de um
instante quadrados furado buscar cortem
as pontas venceu o carro entra sim qual
em bairros como o papel do jornal a
volta para ficar igual a lâmina mesma
espessura da lâmina fina faça um
retângulo em cima de um pedaço de cartão
dos cereais de pequeno-almoço com dois
centímetros por xboxer360 a mina depois
coloca em compasso vai das linhas que
façam como estão a ver marquinhos centro
e faça um circo com três centímetros de
diâmetro
em seguida conecta estas partes
hoje eu fiz duas vezes com o mesmo
design é um deus voltei a parte preta em
um centro e para o outro só tiro em seu
colega combustão modelo utilizando uma
cola branca com quem agora é só colar na
lâmina de forma centralizada qual é uma
partida diferente sexo
além do outro lado
e por fim collor em campo
por pintar outras artes pré e como tal
devem utilizar proteção adequada
mas se vocês não tiverem pode utilizar
30 do ipim pintar com o pincel só para
perceber claramente 1 da lâmina afiada
individualiza essa parte usando fita do
papel
tentei escapar como a esponja nova e se
aquilo que fazemos por já que já usei
várias vezes para fazer este tipo de
efeito de cobrir o cabo precisar de um
pedaço do tecido
no meu caso eu vou usar uma faixa de uma
t shirt tela sempre que dar uma volta
com tecido cola e isso vai evitar que se
estragam mais para frente quando
utilizarem espada para dar um pouco mais
do estilo vocês podem estar um pedaço de
tecido nesta partida
e produção dos campos a fim eu espero
que vocês tenham gostado desse projeto é
que estiverem mais sugestões é só deixar
os comentários que como vocês podem ver
é e vai ser fácil é isso sim e também
assistindo até o próximo dia 13 já
acabou e agora vou fazer outro item